By homocysteine level was high at 15.6, I took methyl B12, right?
So, if person has high homocysteine, that's where you have to take some methyl groups,
either methyl B12 or methyl folate.
They have both our methyl donors.
You have to lower the homocysteine levels.
Did it for two weeks?
It had it rechecked and it dropped to 12.7.
We'll see how fast that is.
That's remarkable.
Unbelievable.
So, it went down, but it's still a little elevated.
Integrated Dr. Woods, we need to keep taking the methyl B12 to get it down further.
I took five days off after the test.
Well, waiting results do you agree that I should keep taking it or should I do another course of action?
No, I agree.
You should keep taking it.
Get that down further and then you could pulse it.
And I don't think you should ever having that level of homocysteine.
I don't think you should ever go off of it for good.
You could go on two days a week or something like that.
So, maybe you're just going to do that Saturday and Sunday.
And you could be able to keep your homocysteine levels at bay that way.
But you could easily do a blood test and make sure you're keeping it at bay.
But you don't want it to get elevated like that.
Why?
Because homocysteine etches that interior of your epithelial cell.
Your walls of your artery, arteries, your endothelial cells.
And damaged endothelial cells, what do they do?
They have these little grooves and they collect cholesterol.
So, and then cholesterol gets to be the bad name that they're the bad guy causing these cholesterol plaques.
And your artery would have really had nothing to do with cholesterol whatsoever.
It's the damaged endothelial cells.